[Musique]
on va pas mettre deux heures bonsoir
pukki pukki je vous rappelle bouki c'est
celle qui voit tout qui nous révèle tout
ce qui se passe dans l'émission et qui
nous révèle des gros gros dossier sur
les chroniqueurs je vais vous l'attendez
chaque semaine lors qu'est ce qui se
passe pour qui est ce que je vous ai
manqué oui moi oui beaucoup à metz alors
tout recommencer on va s'intéresser à un
sujet préféré c'est quoi si vous même si
je sais faire la leche au fait vous je
me sens intégré dans l'équipe pour le
cpmb est un talk show où une belle
émission et des magnétos qui décrypte
l'info mais peu de gens savent que
pendant les magnétos cyril vous êtes
encore en train de faire un travail
d'investigation et pendant les magnétos
vous êtes complètement connecté au sujet
traité
alors est ce enfin presque bah c'est
vrai je regarde tous oui notre jean
pierre pernaut est en pleine forme et il
en a profité jeudi pour flinguer tout le
monde regarde si les français sont
nombreux à le retrouver chaque midi sur
tf1
[Musique]
zizi mais comme là le petit zizi
c'est toi juste après eric vous allez
poser votre question aux téléspectateurs
et aux chroniqueurs c'est parti tout est
question de limite je m'en france dont
la plupart jory très envie de te faire
un spiderman ya des grands l'émission
hier c'est jean michel qui m'a offert il
avait invité christine et isabelle sénat
le parti n'y arrive pas mais qu'un
dirigeant
voilà
jeudi je voudrais magath ont gelé dit
désolé pour qui je vis nation se désole
ne soyez pas désolé est ce que vous
voulez un gros dossier ah ouais bah oui
alors la semaine dernière la marie faye
que cristina cordula était invité dans
l'émission est bien peu la féliciter
parce que ce qu'on ne savait pas c'est
qu'elle était malade et on a de l'eau
féliciter vous aussi cyril 1 pour nous
seuls dans votre discrétion mais aussi
votre courage face à ces je suis fan
d'elle voladores elle est fausse mais
tout ça
[Musique]
attention avec gecina avait la chair
sais pas
à la mi juin qui passe tout madame
histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
the bees prix
[Musique]
hâtez-vous nuque un super émission la
santé syrie la merde ça va très bien non
je crois que j'étais une fausse rumeur
fait tpp on sait maintenant ça ressemble
un petit peu de cours de récré bref
toutes les occasions sont bonnes pour
s'amuser et se faire un petit billet en
passant pendant comment vous êtes des
gamins sérieusement on regarde la suite
16h52 sarlat mandat non non non non non
tu les fais un bisou et une femme ses
bisous dans le cou c'est 50 balles la
prend dans ses bras il apprend dans
témoin rené vous adore mais si tu vas
comme l'a fait je vous adore
pourrais-tu nous sommes 50 maintenant
paraître il s'emballe s'emballe senor
paraître pas dit non pas de son régime
faisait pas tu lui as tu la servante et
marc nom de son rotules à gallo
changement peine
mehtar lam à laval a cité les noms mais
sûrement mais c'est fait pour moi eroglu
et eroglu d'un terreau long tu es devenu
anti d'arca samama chéri d'amour
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] je la donne la gastro c'est mon
partenaire minceur
bah oui la beac en débat c'est bon mais
en plus je n'adore cristina cordula
c'est vrai il y avait cette rumeur qui
flottait voilà c'est tout ouais mais
c'est vrai je les allemands la ba oui
parce que j avais passé après c'est vrai
que c'était vraiment très bon jeu la
dore l'adorent oui d'autres choses vous
avez préfet votre petit encas de ce soir
aucun ou le ventre gargouille je les
laissais dans la loge cette fois ci il
est bien parti
pourquoi la semaine dernière
figurez-vous que c'était la crise
battus à découvert qu'un de ses
collègues lui avaient dérobé ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
[Musique]
c'est pas un niveau quel est le livre de
la nano
sur ma mère n'a pas le moral et on s'en
fout on soit faire il compte en espagne
qui fait peur et qui bouchent coup ça a
marché à 20 ans m'ont choqué du poète
déplacer ça
c'est un tour de chant mesure que les
autres j'ai un peu caoutchouc la semaine
dernière benji vous animiez tpm paie à
la place de cyril après ce raid deux
jours et oui vous allez voir en terme
d'animation bien on est vraiment sûr du
tout pareil que cyril a déjoué en fin de
prêt à le début
[Musique]
devrait on va déjeuner n'est pas partout
aux états unis on voyage d'étude voilà
tout ça au nom de chicago vers les lacs
je connais une en chine voilà ce que
semble penser le giro l'américain
netflix
c'est le 27 septembre dernier que la
plateforme de streaming n'est pas bidon
puisque personne ne connaît l'identité
de ces artistes en fin de saison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais lyon
l endroit
c'est un tabou alors j'adore écouter
c'est donc les chroniqueurs en fin de
semaine ils ont l'air fatigué du coup en
plus d'être animateur belgy le vendredi
vous êtes aussi auxiliaire de vie
concerne tous ça c'est moi je les nie
tout est-ce que vous avez regardé
programme c'est compliqué est-ce que
vous répondra oui non oui non tétouan
avec toi travaux très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
j'ai craqué j'ai grandi et fait crac
houllier est vrai qu à couillet de
l'amour y en a dans l'émission il ya un
petit duo sympa millions qui s'est
formée site une petite évidence entre
ces naulleau et de leur boulot ils
s'adorent week attention parfois de la
haine à l'amour il n'y a qu'un pas ah
ouais qu'un pont que dijon n'a que du
métier de mannequin
il est très bon aussi donc on va voter
pour la beauté m'enchante de leurs
mensualités
c'est catastrophe est devant nous ce
soir
suffit
j'en appelle à vous unir et de partir
avant la fin mai
[Applaudissements]
dix jours plus tôt non genre les
arguments indémontable c'est vous qui
êtes indémontable c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
est-ce que vous
mais qu'est ce qu'il veut
policière avec nous lors du couvreur et
pour en bus à tout ça est fait de
manière effectivement avec l'hypocrisie
jamais devant moi n'ose jamais un
village et bien le match et était il en
est une autre
non moi pas du tout non non non non non
ici pas autre chose à coups de lattes
elle qui a déjà regardé confessions
intimes sa démission que j'adore c'est
mon émission préférée
et bien justement on a un épisode inédit
en préparation c'est quoi
mais c'est sûr vous baba son histoire
j'ai un toc
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de mettre les
objets des benjamins voulait voir les
premières images il est c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
moi
non je fais ce que l'on me venger mais
ce n'est mieux mais je savais le faire à
vos bouteilles inquiétez pas vous avez
vous avez vu quoi bein c'est bon
compromis
d'autres choses ma peau qui ne va pas
c'est la petite minute
autun pour détendre et si on parlait de
la poitrine de christine kelly qui
passionne pas mal de monde autour de la
table et on la dorcas et enfin surtout
un tailleur autour de la table c'était j
[Applaudissements]
alors encore regardé les images vont
faire entrer christine kelly qui nous
fera son témoignage si jamais comme ça
c'est trop beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on va passer d'un style ma série des
valises
mais qu'est ce qu'il est allé j'aurai je
sais que vous êtes très amis dont vous
pouvez voilà a passé bien